[Música]
mientras yo esté bien
que me importan los demás
aunque me acaban de presentar
y yo siempre he dicho que los puestos
que has tenido no te describen
pero tus gustos tus hobbies también tus
pasatiempos a lo que le dedicas el
tiempo te pueden describir mejor
yo soy agus dorantes
soy amante de las garnachas
de los tacos
también soy me acabo de casar
soy un joven con muchos sueños
los tacos francia soy boxeador en
potencia o al menos eso es la risa la
que cae o al menos que dice mi
entrenador que por cierto me pide que le
pague por adelantado
además me gusta jugar fútbol los
domingos
soy un joven con muchos sueños
me gusta leer
soy fan de joaquín sabina por supuesto
los que me conocen saben que no escucho
otra cosa que no sea al maestro sabina y
además estoy muy orgulloso de lo que
significa querétaro
como cualquier queretano
de los que nacimos o decidimos vivir en
querétaro
creemos que querétaro es de los estados
y de las ciudades más lindas para vivir
para mí es un reto estar aquí en frente
de ustedes
porque hace rato me decían es que tú
hablas mucho en público pero siempre
hablas como político y hoy vengo no a
hablar como político servidor público
sino vengo a hablar como agustín a agus
el funk de joaquín sabina y amante del
buen tequila y para hacer algo distinto
con esta plática esta charla
abajo de ustedes si buscan abajo de sus
sillas van a encontrar una paleta como
estas que dice si de un la notan de
abajo
que dice de un lado sí y de un lado no y
la idea es que me ayuden a contestar
algunas preguntas
para ver si todos coincidimos o no en
las preguntas que vamos realizando
antes de continuar
estoy seguro que han escuchado
que han dicho o que han pensado
algunas de las frases que les voy a
decir
el que no tranza no avanza se han
escuchado o no han escuchado el que no
tranza no avanza o lo han dicho lo han
pensado
esta tal vez no lo hayan escuchado pues
está buena este es el año de hidalgo
chingue a su madre el que deje algo le
han escuchado o no algunos no algunos si
él no es les explico en el último año de
gobierno a los servidores públicos
supuestamente como es el último año
dicen que es el año de hidalgo y que se
tienen que llevar todo lo que hay está
seguro que todos han escuchado un pobre
político un político pobre es un pobre o
un pobre político le han escuchado
a mí me la han dicho
todos los políticos son corruptos le han
escuchado no
se siente bien gacho yo soy político
ahora quiero que me digan qué piensan de
estas imágenes o si saben quiénes es el
exgobernador garnier era gobernador de
tabasco
agarraron a su secretaria con estos
fajos de dinero y esta fue cuando
realizaron la orden de aprehensión y ya
habían visto esta foto están de acuerdo
con esta foto donde acuerdo no están de
acuerdo
más bien están de acuerdo no están de
acuerdo pues nadie está de acuerdo con
esta foto no nadie quisiera que nuestros
servidores públicos a los que escogimos
terminarán en este tipo de imágenes
seguramente también conocen al señor de
las ligas alejarán a bejarano están de
acuerdo o no con este tipo de políticos
nadie está de acuerdo creo que todos por
unanimidad nada más se nos fue un sí que
seguramente lo pusimos al revés no creo
que nadie esté de acuerdo o duarte el la
persona que ha niños con cáncer en lugar
de darle su medicina le dio este agua
esta es la política que no queremos tan
de acuerdo pero también hay otro tipo de
personas que han participado en política
porque cualquier persona que participe
en política no tiene que ser servidor
público es un político materia terquin
como ustedes saben transformó en el
siglo pasado las diferencias raciales
todos conocemos el discurso de yo tengo
un sueño y sin duda todos estamos de
acuerdo con materia terquim
o también todos estamos de acuerdo aquí
en méxico con lo que sucedió en el
terremoto del 2017 y la sociedad
mexicana se avasalló para ayudar a las
personas que estaban padeciendo después
del terremoto todos estamos de acuerdo
no hay bien la pregunta más difícil del
día
les gusta o no les gusta esta foto
si o no
levanten la mano sí sí o sí no
hay 6 y ahí nos
vamos a verla con detenimiento
los que contestaron que les gustaba la
foto les sigue gustando esta foto
la bates que no va
esto es lo que sucede todos los días
vivimos en un mundo materialista
individualista donde no vemos no
observamos lo que realmente está
sucediendo al de al lado
es la pobreza que existe en todo méxico
que existe en querétaro y que existe en
todo el mundo esto fue en san miguel
allende
porque escogí este tema
después de hacer una investigación y
revisar un análisis que hizo harvard
acerca de cuáles eran los objetivos de
los chavos millennials chaux ya no tan
chavos decían que el 80% de ellos habían
contestado que uno de sus objetivos
era ser rico
o sea lo que quieren los jóvenes de este
mundo es tener billete todos queremos
que nos vaya bien
y el 50% de este mismo 100% había gente
que contestaba a las dos cosas dijo que
era ser famoso
o sea lo que quieren los objetivos más
importantes de los jóvenes de este
planeta es ser rico y ser famoso
este más seguramente tengo las mismas
oportunidades que muchos de los que
están aquí pero gracias a que trabajo en
el servicio público me han tocado
conocer realidades muy distintas y
quiero poner tres ejemplos de cómo veo
yo las diferencias en el mundo
la primera
y la que más me significa porque lo viví
de forma les digo yo a la gente que
trabajaba conmigo yo fui secreta
desarrollo social 2015 2018 te toca ver
el rostro de la pobreza
esta fue una de las primeras anécdotas o
de las primeras vivencias más bien que
viví como secretario fui a landa de
matamoros
estábamos en unos honores a la bandera y
se me acerca una ni ninguna niña
empujada en una silla de ruedas por su
mano y me en cuenta me cuenta su
historia
y al igual que ustedes y yo porque no
veo a nadie que no lo sé pero pareciera
que nadie tiene alguna discapacidad
la niña había nacido bien sana sin
ningún problema de alguna enfermedad
pero por las condiciones de pobreza en
las que vivía su cuarto era de láminas
sus paredes eran de madera se filtraba
la lluvia se filtraba el viento y tuvo
una enfermedad crónica respiratoria que
le cambió la vida para siempre se volvió
dependiente a su mamá y el apoyo de la
gente que está alrededor mi papá siempre
me dijo este mi papá es una persona muy
chambeador y dijo si trabajas te paras
templada no eres disciplinado te va a ir
bien en la vida y también a cualquiera
que lo haga
pero al conocer el rostro de la
desigualdad y la pobreza
te das cuenta que no es así que vivimos
en condiciones desiguales que vivimos en
un mundo injusto que vivimos en un mundo
donde no todos tienen las mismas
oportunidades
el segundo tema que les quiero compartir
como ustedes saben la onu acaba de
presentar una investigación de cómo
vamos como se va desarrollando el
planeta como éste estamos contaminando o
no a nuestro planeta lo que dijo la onu
fue que en 30 años ciudades como nueva
orleans que es la que está aquí enfrente
o como tokio o también playas en méxico
como cancún van a desaparecer por el
descongelamiento de los polos
lógicamente sube el nivel del agua y
todo lo que está más abajo se quede
inundado
ocho millones de personas fallecieron
por la mala calidad del aire ese es el
mundo que estamos construyendo todos
nosotros todos los días
todos generamos basura y todos somos
parte del problema
hace poquito
presentamos un exhorto para que peña
colorada fuera un área natural protegida
por la federación y pongo este ejemplo
porque vi tres o cuatro realidades
primero los ejidatarios que trataban de
proteger su interés de este tener un uso
distinto a la conservación de los
terrenos que tenían los ejidatarios
normalmente no todos pueden vivir en
condiciones este de marginación
vi también a los ambientalistas hubo dos
o tres muy aguerridos que salieron a
medios que llevaron a sus hijos al cerro
y que trataron de hacer un movimiento
para garantizar esas más de 4000
hectáreas
250 especies de fauna y 170 especies de
flora al revés 250 especies de flora y
170 de fauna
y le echaron muchas ganas para que se
conservará peña colorada como área
natural protegida federal
se acercaron muchos empresarios que
tienen intereses allá dentro
tratando de evitar de que se hiciera
este exhorto para buscar que no se
hiciera área natural protegida la peña
colorada y por otro lado también tuvimos
este a la ciudadanía
qué le pasó indiferente ni fú ni fá el
abad es que a pesar de que eran los que
les iba a afectar que si nos íbamos
inundar más que íbamos a perder en
especies que eran endémicas que la
calidad del aire en la ciudad dependía
de ese pulmón urbano a la ciudad a pesar
de que los medios le dieron mucha mucho
eco no le importó
y mi tercer anécdota no me pasó a mi
persona anécdota que cuando me la
contaron me sensibilizó muy cañón luís
corripio se fue de misiones a oaxaca
hace unos 15 años iba con un equipo de
misioneros llega a una comunidad de
oaxaca había un chavito que estaba
molestando a los demás y molestando a
los demás y molestando a los demás
también molestaba a los misioneros no
dejaba que las actividades se realizarán
y uno de los misioneros ya enfadado le
pone las manos en el pecho y el niño
empieza a gritar
y cuando empieza a gritar de dolor todos
se espantan dijo piqué le hizo parecía
que no había sido nada grave pero el
niño gritó grito lo llevaron al doctor
el doctor lo revisó y cuando sale del
doctor
les dice conocen a sus padres y
contestan los conocemos ya hace poquito
somos misioneros este precio nos ha
hablado con ellos lo que pasa es que
este niño ha sido abusado sexualmente
crónicamente sistemáticamente y tiene
roto el ano
lógicamente louis me cuenta lo que
sintió en el estómago lo que sigue
sintiendo cada vez que cuenta esta
anécdota
este
y esa es la realidad del mundo en el que
vivimos vivimos en un mundo donde hay
gente que sufre en niños que no tienen
las mismas oportunidades que nosotros
donde hay pobreza y donde hay una
sociedad que parece que todos estos
problemas pasan desapercibidos
esta fotografía seguro la conocen fue un
premio pulitzer este después de tres
años de que se tomó el cuate que la tomó
se suicidó porque contó que había visto
muchas cosas que le habían afectado este
porque ha visto la desigualdad del mundo
y por último no vuelvo usar las tablets
las paletas les pregunto creen que
vivimos en la mejor versión del mundo
entonces después de tratar de
sensibilizarlos con lo que me ha tocado
vivir con lo que otros han vivido
tenemos problemas las tres anécdotas son
aquí en méxico
este quiero proponerles
tres acciones para ser felices porque
para poder cambiar el mundo debemos de
ser felices nosotros y nuestros entornos
y la primera frase que a mí últimamente
la anunció no en todos lados es aunque
nada cambia si yo cambio todo cambia de
the mars el post
lo primero que les quiero decir es para
ser felices yo creo que aquí lo que
tenemos que entender es que venimos a
este mundo a ser felices si pensamos que
nuestro objetivo en la vida es el dinero
y la fama pues nadie de nosotros va a
ser feliz faltan muchas cosas por hacer
en el mundo desde tener mejores
relaciones interpersonales
desde ser más humildes desde ser más
conscientes de nuestro entorno desde
cuidar el planeta
desde ayudar al prójimo desde ponernos
en los zapatos de los demás y las
primeras tres acciones o primeros tres
principios o primeros tres ejes llámenle
como quieran es primero no vivimos solos
si entendemos que la felicidad es una
felicidad de egoístas mientras que yo
esté bien que chinguen la suma de los
demás
entonces ni ustedes ni los de enfrente
ni los de al lado van a ser felices para
que para que tú seas feliz necesitas
mejorar tu entorno necesitas que el de
enfrente sea feliz necesitas que tu
pareja esté feliz
necesitas ponerte en los zapatos del de
enfrente
el segundo principio es en el mundo sólo
hay un mismo mes yo soy un cristiano
ronaldo todos seremos queremos ser el
más guapo todos queremos ser el mejor el
más millonario todos queremos ser el
mejor futbolista
todos queremos tener más dinero o ser el
gran inventor no va a pasar
la felicidad se encuentra en los
detalles y los detalles son estas
relaciones personales que tienes con tu
esposa con tu esposo estas relaciones
personales que tienes con tus hijos con
tu vecino con tus amigos
esa posibilidad de educar a tus hijos y
darles el conocimiento de que se puede
construir un mundo mejor
y el tercer principio que quiero
compartirles es no podemos ser felices
en un infierno
y estamos acabando el único planeta que
tenemos mi pregunta sería o somos parte
de la solución o somos parte del
problema y pareciera que hoy los seres
humanos estamos siendo parte del
problema pero como no podemos cambiar al
mundo más que podemos cambiar nosotros y
si cambiamos nosotros cambiamos el mundo
mi pregunta es la siguiente
qué vas a hacer tú
para cambiar tu mundo para ser feliz
para cambiar el mundo de tu pareja para
cambiar el mundo de tu familia para
cambiar el mundo de tu vecino para
participar en tu entorno para cuidar el
medio ambiente
porque al final de cuentas
y lo repito si no eres parte de la
solución eres parte del problema de que
el lado de la historia que es jugar
hay una frase de galliano que me gusta
mucho que dice mucha gente pequeña en
lugares pequeños haciendo cosas pequeñas
pueden cambiar el mundo ya en esa gente
pequeña que quiere cambiar el mundo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]